I want to compete with the stories I've created.I do
n't want to become a new writer because of my older sister's stories.Oh, I'm
making a suggestion based on your wisdom, but it's a lie.There's no way I'll be
able to read it that quickly, Mr. Ellis.  It's
good to remember one thing. I don't
like lying. That's
right. The good thing about this story
is that the main character, the prince, is portrayed in a very charming way. He has a somewhat toxic personality.  The
dialogue with the dragon was also very funny.The
blood fight scene with Simon from the enemy on the bridge, the
moment when they exchanged swords and hit each other with passionate bamboo sticks,
was irresistible.
What is Himetenkan?
How do you know all the parts that haven't been written yet
? That's right. What I know is what's written
several years from now, and what's
written even after what's going on now.  So I didn't
think about it and talked about it comfortably. I'm
not surprised. If you're
like Ellis, you can easily understand the flow of the story if you read up to it.
Ludwig is pretty much the same, but
Anne is also a very seriously ill patient.  Oh,
that's what it feels like. It seems scary.
Ah, this person
was Anne's younger sister.